hallo herzlich willkommen zur verließ
welt ich weiß viele von euch das video
schon sehnsüchtig erwartet
für die anderen möchte ich vorweg kurz
was erzählen ihr wisst ja dass ich
meinen eigenen shop habe und in meinem
shop nämlich einfach dinge auf die mir
gefallen die ich gut finde
das heißt ich geh auf messen auf
haushaltswaren messen zum beispiel und
nehmen einfach sachen dann in den shop
auf die ich vorher getestet habe und die
ich gut finde
in meinem shop dreht sich natürlich
alles um haushalte und die küche und so
weiter ihr kennt mich ja und dieses jahr
war ich auch wieder auf der ambiente
messe wie bereits im letzten jahr ich
hatte euch ja auch schon ein video dazu
veröffentlicht wenn ihr das nochmal
sehen wollt können wir in die infobox
schauen und wir sind jetzt seit längerem
als er muratow nicht ich sag jetzt mal
wie er später sagte er wieder dürfe
nicht immer wir sind seit längerem schon
auf der suche gewesen
nach einem richtig guten blender ist ein
blender wie katina der kamera steht
ich habe meinen weg schon gesehen
moratorium raum sind genau sondern und
blender ist einfach ein mixer und ich
hab halt zwar auch schon und blender zu
hause gehabt an der küchenmaschine dran
aber ich habe jetzt in diesem fall
einfach nach einem hochleistungs blender
gesucht also ein power mixa und hab mir
da einfach verschiedene modelle von
verschiedenen marken auf der messe
angeschaut und jetzt im endeffekt habe
ich mich für den kitchenaid magnetik
drei länder entschieden und wird euch
jetzt einfach in dem video sagen wieso
warum was es wasser an vorteile bietet
und eben was man eben damit machen kann
viele denken nämlich immer dass man so
einen blender einfach dafür benutzt um
zum beispiel musik zu machen
aber im prinzip kann man so ein blender
für vielerlei rezepte benutzen
und natürlich werde ich jetzt
wahrscheinlich wieder gefragt brauch ich
das muss ich mir das holen natürlich
müsst ihr das nicht also egal was sie in
der küche macht gesund sind nicht eure
küchenmaschinen oder die geräte die ihr
zuhause anschafft gesund in teure
zutaten
das heißt jeder kann sich gesund und
ausgewogen ernähren ohne dass er sich
irgendwas kaufen muss um es einfach die
richtigen zutaten und die richtigen
lebensmittel kaufen
am besten immer saisonale produkte
regionale produkte und dann seid ihr
immer auf der sicheren seite
ihr müsst euch auf den blende kaufen die
könnte auch ein
darin würden da heiraten sowie ist auf
jeden fall haben wir uns dafür
entschieden einfach aus verschiedenen
gründen ihr wisst ja ich habe die samira
meine vierjährige tochter
und es ist meistens und kampf mit ihr
wenn es ums essen geht also ich glaube
wer selber eine tochter oder sohn hat
weiß wovon ich spreche muss jetzt am
esstisch martin salat gemacht und ich
sagte komm jetzt ist doch mal an salaten
heißt wieder normal keinen salat oder
obst und gemüse klein so als zwischen
snack dann ist sie ein paar mal
unterricht bleibt wieder liegen also ich
möchte meine tochter zunächst zwingen
aber man möchte natürlich auch dass das
kind sich eben gesund ernährt und eben
auch viel obst und viel gemüse zu sich
nimmt
und deswegen haben wir für uns
entschieden also der moratorium von wir
ja wir müssen zusammen entschieden du
entscheidest zahl stimmt da nicht
wir haben für uns entschieden dass es
für uns die beste lösung ist wenn wir
obst und gemüse einfach trinken hat sich
jetzt zwar im ersten moment ziemlich
komisch an aber bei uns hat es einfach
ja das hat sich einfach bewährt also
werde ich mich mit samir eine küche
stelle mit ihr obst gemüse klein
schnitzler ist das zwar auch aber eben
nicht so viel wie ich gerne hätte und
wenn wir das zusammen dann zum beispiel
in so ein blender reinschmeißen dann
trinkt sie eben 1 2 gläser davon und hat
einfach ihre portionen obst und gemüse
am tag gedeckt und deswegen haben wir
uns dafür entschieden und ich möchte
euch jetzt einfach zeigen dass dieser
blender jetzt nicht nur dafür da ist
musik zu machen sondern man kann echt
verschiedene sachen damit machen ich
kann darin kalte suppen machen ich kann
auch warme suppen soßen mixen
ich kann baby preise nennt herstellen
was er bald wieder bei uns im thema
endspiel hieß damals schon selber
gemacht und dieses mal ist auch wieder
selber machen und einfach ganz viel
verschiedene möglichkeiten also zuerst
möchte ich euch mal was zum äußeren
sagen den blender gibt es in sieben
verschiedenen farben
ich habe mich jetzt für das rot
entschieden weil ihr wisst ja ich habe
auch den stabmixer in roth ich hab das
waffeleisen
wasserburger in rot deswegen passt dass
jetzt da ganz gut dazu und ich finde
sich halter und design das sieht halt
total modern aus und total hübsch also
ich kenne habe ich keinen anderen power
mixa der so oder so ähnlich aussieht
also richtig schön designt und mit
könnten vielleicht manche sagen ja gut
das sieht zwar gut aus aber er kann
wahrscheinlich nichts aber da kann ich
euch echt vom gegenteil überzeugen
also bei dem blender ist es echt so der
hat zwei ps das muss man sich erst mal
vorstellen
hofer nach schmelz damit sagen ich habe
keine zweifel ist es und er hat sollte
genau und der länder hat zwei ps und
20.000 umdrehungen
außerdem ist das besondere bei denen der
hand halten magnet antrieben also das
leben auch ganz gut hier der technics
nicht so eine kupplung wie bei anderen
mixa mehr inhalt im mixer drauf steckt
sondern der ich david magnetisch
angetrieben
ich finde sowieso total genial als ich
hab so was als nicht sehen und das
besondere stand auch ich kann den von
vorn bedient also wieso eine
kaffeemaschine seine filter maschine
kann man einfach von diesem programm
reinstecken und muss all den group nicht
wie bei anderen jetzt einfach oben drauf
stecken
das hat er den vorteil jetzt zum
beispiel bei mir in der küche ich hab
hier hinten auch diese hoch schränke und
dann kann ich halt diesen blender dem
habt ihr auch schon in mehreren videos
gesehen kann ich dann einfach hinten
unten unter der arbeit auf der
arbeitsplatte unter hoch schranken
stehen lassen und bedienten ja von vorne
das heißt ich muss den mixed ständig
wieder vorziehen weil ich das ding
obendrauf stecken muss sondern es ist
platzsparend und ich kann deshalb total
leicht bedienen
dieser blender ist wie meine kitchenaid
hintergrund auch aus gusseisen das heißt
die ist sehr schwer zu spielen jetzt
nicht hoch tragen
der [ __ ] hat sie mir über getragen aber
das ist hat hat den vorteil dass die
maschine stehen bleibt auch wenn ich
jetzt die höchste leistung
geschwindigkeit einstellt das heißt die
wackel nicht darum kann ich von der
arbeitsfläche runterfallen und das ist
eben ganz wichtig gerade bei
hochleistungs-
mix an das andere ist das messer was man
im inneren hat das ist ein stumpfes
messer und wenn ich jetzt überlegen als
ich dachte immer so messer müssen dann
halt extrem scharf sein damit sie eben
gut mixen
aber es ist genau das gegenteil und zwar
muss man sich so vorstellen also so
konnte ich mir halt richtig vorstellen
sie streckten wesentlich aber ich hätte
sich trotzdem wenn man jetzt überlegt
ihr vater im auto und haltet jetzt zum
beispiel ein scharfes messer oder noch
fast tägliche aus dem fenster raus und
dann kommt eine fliege und wird halt
dadurch halbiert es stellt euch vor
dieses scharfe messer weil in diesem mix
da drin und es wird sich halt drehen und
müsste praktisch jetzt nicht die fliege
aber zb das obst oder gemüse stück immer
wieder praktisch halbieren und treffen
und wieder treffen und wieder treffen
und es wird ja ständig halbieren
missstände euch mal vor ihr fahrt ganz
schnell den neuen auto und dann kommt
eine fliege und stößt ein ries vorne an
diese stoßstange auf was passiert mit
ihr die wird nicht halbiert sondern die
zerplatzt direkt 12 ja aber solche es
hat auch in den mixer also dieses
stumpfe messer
was dann praktisch das obst und gemüse
zerschlägt sorgt eben dafür dass das
obst und gemüse direkt zu brei
zerschlagen wird also praktisch wie die
fliege halt an der stoßstange also jetzt
und das so bitte ich euch mal rüber zu
bringen
aber so konnte ich mir das halt ganz gut
vorstellen und deswegen ist es ganz
wichtig dass man ein stumpfes messer hat
in sonnen in seinem power mixa und vor
allem hat natürlich den riesenvorteil
das stumpfe messer kanalnetz stumpf
weiter also ein scharfes messer mit
stumpfen stumpfe station stumpf das
heißt ihr habt keine wartungsarbeiten
müsste nicht einschicken und so weiter
das macht sich draußen sind ja so
logisch so ist es halt so muss erklären
und bei dem behälter so bei diesem mix
krug das ist kein schwerer behälter weil
er nicht aus glas ist aber er ist
trotzdem hitzebeständig das heißt ich
kann darin auch heiße soßen und suppen
zum beispiel drin
pürieren und kein machen und so weiter
aber das schafft richtig praktisch weil
man nichts mega schweres in der hand
sondern die maschine an sich ist eben
schwer der blende es auch
spülmaschinengeeignet und man kann ihn
einfach mit rein stellen den deckel mit
rein und dann ist er eben auch wieder
ganz schnell sauber
bei dem blender es ist so ich habe jetzt
hier einfach schon viel verschiedene
vorprogrammierte stufen
aber ich kann zum beispiel hier auch so
ausgangspunkt ist nun da ist es ganz
neutral da kann ich hier auf tkp heißt
impuls geben das heißt ich steuer das
dann manuell und kann hier zum beispiel
eine heiße suppe oder eine heiße soße
eingeben und dann ein wasser okay jetzt
richtig den und koloriert kann das
praktisch selber steuern dann kann ich
auf die zweite stufe gehen da sieht man
so ein apfel so ein halben apfel mit zu
einem tropfen dran und das ist einfach
die stufe wo ihr zum beispiel saft
herstellen könnt oder ihr könnt da eben
auch eure smoothies fein mixen weil es
wirklich dann einfach durchgehen zum
programm ist das ist vorprogrammiert
sind ist eine gewisse anzahl an sekunden
und dann wird es eben richtig fein
gemacht stoppt aber irgendwann vor allem
ab einer gewissen temperatur und das ist
heute gerade bei säften bei smoothies
wichtig denn ihr habt ja in rom obst und
gemüse eben vitamine und mineralstoffe
drin
und manche vitamine zum beispiel sinne
hitzeresistent das heißt sie würden
absterben wenn sie jetzt über eine
bestimmte temperatur kommen und da ist
es eben so dass der mix al-islam
verhindert und dann einfach stockt die
nächste einstellung ist hier diese mit
dem schälchen also sieht aus wie seine
suppen schale und bei der es so da könnt
ihr zum beispiel suppen und saucen
pürieren und kleinen mixen und es
einfach damit regeln oder auch wie genau
oder auch eben nach die nächste
einstellung ist die mit dem milchshake
drauf da können leckere milchshakes
mixen und die letzte einstellung ist die
mit dem eis da könnt ihr einst raschen
oder zum beispiel auch geeiste getränke
herstellen
und wenn ihr jetzt sagt keine von den
einstellungen passt zu dem rezept was
ich jetzt gern machen möchte nehmt ihr
wie gesagt entweder diese impuls taste
oder ihr könnt es auch manuell steuern
und praktisch hier manuell die ihn die
geschwindigkeit regeln
so schön wird seinen aufzug ja ganz
angenehm
moritz grad bei angenehmen geräuschen
sind also der blender hat er seine zwei
ps und 20.000 umdrehen und der es hat
natürlich auch relativ laut es ist jetzt
nicht so laut wie wenn im rat mit seinem
hof durch unsere wohnung fahren würde
aber es ist schon ein lauter blender
das heißt ich kann das nicht vergleichen
mit der pid staates an die mal kurz
meint eickholt sondern das ist halt
schon ein lauteres gerät aber es kommt
eben dadurch zustande dass er eben diese
ganze power hat um die leistung bringt
und ja ich bin ein schlage man weder den
ganzen straße nicht aus es stimmt was
jetzt bei uns daheim noch ganz wichtig
ist weil ich ja die samira habe und die
gern mit mir in der küche arbeitet steht
bei mir eben die sicherheit auch im
vordergrund und deswegen fand es ganz
gut das eben bei diesem blender
dieser mix trug von vorne bedienbar ist
praktisch und einfach und clip dran der
den mix behälter drin behält und oben
ist es natürlich auch so dass die
öffnung sehr klein ist und daher oder
drin steckt und ich oben zum beispiel
noch als nachfüllen kann wenn ich jetzt
gerade im mix borken bin
es hat die öffnung ganz klein das heißt
dass hand oder auch andere kinderhände
passende halt nicht rein
am anfang ist immer ziemlich aufgeregt
weil wir gedacht aber auch jetzt muss
man die gurke doch halbieren oder das
gemüse wie so kleiner schneiden und da
habe aber dass er kommen lieber
schneiden gemüse einmal durch statt
mein kind zu gefährden also ich find
sicherheit steht einfach im vordergrund
und in deutschland ist es anders gar
nicht zugelassen also egal welche
küchengeräte es sind die müssen immer so
sein dass keine kinderhand eben rein
geht und was noch ganz super war und was
sich im ort erklären musste und zwar in
dieser clip hier zum beispiel den mixer
reinstecken
aber der klub dann
so ist dann funktioniert der mixa nicht
das ist halt aus und sicherheitsaspekt
wenn dieser clip nicht drin steckt
stecken und dann funktioniert der mixa
ist genauso wie halt erst der deckel
drauf sein muss und ihr dann erst mixen
kann hat sich nämlich der moral nicht
gewundert und hat sich beschwert dass
der mix an es funktioniert und hat sich
hinsetzt mit dem buch also mit dem
gebrauchsanleitung wie sich ihnen dann
gesagt habe du deinen mixtape delikt
nebendran jetzt nichts mehr
ja normal also komm mal vergessen aber
mit wundern wenn das nicht funktioniert
das heißt dann einfach irgendwas stimmt
nicht entweder ist der clip nicht so
damit findet er nicht richtig drin oder
der deckel fehlt und die sind einfach
sicherheits aspekte die man beachten
muss und dann funktioniert der blender
hat übrigens sieben jahre garantie
und ich mache es auch bei diesem länder
wie mit der kitsch nicht genauso ich
habe da meinen fachhändler mit dem ich
zusammenarbeite und ihr könnt es wenn
ihr möchtet einfach über mich über einen
shop bestellen
und ich hab da einfach ein paket
zusammengeschnürt das paket ändert sich
immer mal wieder und ich werde euch da
einfach in der infobox den link
reinschreiben bzw ihr könnt direkt immer
auch sallys - shop.de gehen und dadurch
das paket einfach anschauen
jetzt möchte ich einfach noch ganz kurz
ein paar rezept beispiele zeigen
wirklich nur kurz anschneiden und
einfach zeigen was man eben alles damit
machen kann und dass so ein power mixer
oder sind power blender eben nicht nur 1
movie maker ist sondern einfach ganz
viele verschiedene möglichkeiten bietet
ich möchte zuerst mal eine kalte gurken-
zu vermachen
das ist etwas was dem sommer immer ganz
gerne essen weil es einfach schön
erfrischend ist es geht schnell die
total einfach und ich brauche nur ganz
wenige zutaten dafür nehme ich mir jetzt
eine gurke und stücke differenz kopie
reicht
dann kommt noch etwas wasser mittels und
noch etwas joghurt etwas salz und
pfeffer und dann noch etwas minze von
meinem kräutergarten auf der terrasse
wer möchte könne dies auch noch ein
bisschen knoblauch nehmen aber ich
später noch unternehmen hat kein
knoblauch
jetzt gehe ich auch die einstellung
suppen und saucen und lass das ganze ist
schön vermissen
ich muss jetzt im prinzip gar nichts
machen
die maschine hat nämlich einfach das
programm abgespeckt kommt für suppen und
saucen und ich glaube jetzt einfach mal
das ergebnis jetzt können wir die suppe
natürlich noch mal kalt stellen die kann
scheint durchziehen oder ihr könnt sie
einfach zu verwehren so schnell wie das
jetzt ging hat wenig meine tütensuppe
auf gemacht geschweige denn zubereitet
und die zutaten waren alle bei mir im
kühlschrank habe ich immer zu hause und
vor allem durch die konsistenz hat auch
richtig schön kriegen ist als nächstes
möchte ich euch jetzt mal lennons musik
machen und vor einem grünen smoothie
nicht sag ich jetzt einfach mal kurz ein
paar zutaten als grundlage nehme ich am
liebsten etwas grünes also hier zum
beispiel etwas wir sehen hier etwas
spinnert dann nämlich über baby spinat
das grün von ein paar karotten ich haben
salat oder hier auch feldsalat und dann
nehmt ihr euch noch ein obst zum
beispiel wie hier ananas äpfel
ich habe ich noch bananen oder trauben
etwas was eben süße mit rein bringt
gerne könnt ihr den mut wie auch
verfeinern mit zb einer bio zitrone und
ihr braucht dann natürlich auch noch
eine flüssigkeit entweder wasser gerne
auch etwas eiswürfel oder wie hier zum
beispiel haben wir bereits den saft
einer kokosnuss mit rausgelassen oder
unten oder ein tier zum beispiel genau
und viele benutzen zum beispiel auch
gerade bei grünen
movies irgendwelche
nahrungsergänzungsmittel oder zum
beispiel dieses super fuß so was wie
gute wm-erfahrung oder irgendwelche
andere nahrungsergänzungsmittel die man
aber im prinzip alle gar nicht braucht
ich finde zuerst einmal viel viel zu
überteuert
also ich glaube so ein häkchen kasan rus
8 euro sind 200 gramm drin
diese goji beeren kosten sind 250 gramm
kosten auch acht bis neun euro
und vor allem ist oft das problem gerade
bei diesem gut wenn zb die sind sehr auf
pestizide belastet 80 prozent glauben 80
von denen sind pestizide belastet die
kommen jetzt zum beispiel aus tibet
tibet wissen wir alle auch ich als nicht
geografie kennerin weiß dass er in china
ist und auch so was kann man einfach
verzichten erspart erstmal geld und man
spart sich einfach befestigt und
relativierte linken ist irgendwie wie
zwischen münchen genauer und morgens
raus und das stimmt gar nicht
dabei finde sie cool gesunden zutaten
ihr braucht alle bei euch zu hause bzw
in eurer region die samira hatten zum
beispiel zum muttertag und so ein pub
vater zweiter grund ist ein weizenglas
angepflanzt also dazu mache ich euch mal
ein extra video gratis auch über weiten
kreis und über dieses super putz &
nahrungsergänzung und so weiter und ich
hab mir jetzt zum beispiel dieses pool
vorhalt gekauft weil bei weizengras ist
es einfach so man kann das war so
anfangen und wenn sie dann so sieben bis
zehn zentimeter groß sind also das
einfach mal weizenkörner solides kennen
und wenn die dann so groß sind kann man
sie eben abschneiden und verzehren
allerdings braucht man dafür einen extra
weizengras entsafter weil du ansonsten
diese stoffe gar nicht raus bekommt bzw
dein körper die annett verwerten kann
und deswegen haben wir uns jetzt zb
dieses buch gekauft weil wir halt keinen
weizengras
auf daten aus dem einfach kommen ich
nehme es als grundlage etwas spinat
thema immer ein baby spinat weil er halt
relativ wenig ob server hat und zu viel
oxalsäure sollte hat zu sich nehmen
dann ist es ganz wichtig beim snow wer
in diesem blender jemand von weich
nachtschichten das heißt die weichen
zutaten wird salat und spinat kommt
unten rein
ich nehme knopf für bis und karotte grün
nicht erschrecken aber das kommt hier
wirklich rein denn im karotten grünig
spiegeln vielmehr die nährstoffe zum
einsatz in der karte zum beispiel vor
ort durch die karotte arbeit rein ja
auch betreiben dann natürlich was süßes
ansonsten schmeckt es nämlich nicht
deswegen nehme ich jetzt hier so ein
paar traum und das ist halt so cool weil
hab mir das am meer macht es hat total
spaß sucht sich dann müssen obst und
gemüse ausmaß ist am rhein
dann macht uns das wasser rein und zieht
einfach wie das alles schon vermisst
wird bei ihr sie jetzt grünes netz so
sehr
jetzt im moment zumindest wie zum
beispiel rote die schwestern ein paar
erdbeeren mit reinen himbeeren und so
weiter und da ist die halt total
begeistert und trinkt es halt abwehren
wichtig ist jetzt dass sich wasser nehme
und das mixed messer kommt mit dem
wasser auch gedeckt ist so wie es hier
jetzt mache ich das natürlich hier auf
die stufe mit dem apfel also für säfte
und smoothies und wenn ihr jetzt im
nachhinein daneben auch noch
reinschmeißen wollt könnt ihr das auch
während dem laufen machen also ich würde
gern funktionen mit reingeben gibt das
kiffen mit rein
also wenn ich im nachhinein was einfällt
einfach mit dazu heimspiel
das ist im prinzip einfach in flüssiger
salat sozusagen
aber wer nimmt schon zuflüssen satz
gesichert natürlich gibt es diese
smoothies vor allem auch für sie brünen
smoothies oder auch andere smoothies
bereits fertig zu kaufen und die
schmecken auch echt richtig gut vor
allem steckt da wirklich nur obst und
gemüse mit drin
ich weiß es nicht wo sie hergestellt
werden abgepackt steht jetzt hier zum
beispiel in baden württemberg also bei
uns im land und die sind natürlich sehr
lecker aber die sind einfach ziemlich
teuer also eine kleine flasche prosecco
ab 3 euro
und wenn ihr jetzt überlege wie viel mut
wie ich am tag trinken also ich trink
locker zwei bis drei von diesen
fläschchen bleibt also auch als als
menge jetzt gerechnet heißt für mich
anscheinend so eine große flasche die
kostet knapp fünf euro
wenn ich jetzt nicht nur mit rechnern
sondern auch den mut und die samira wenn
wir ungefähr bei 15 euro am tag auf den
monat gerechnet ist es natürlich ein
haufen geld muss er raus was ist da
agiert und zu wasser und gas genau
deswegen finde ich es einfach selber zu
machen
und wenn man die halt wirklich so
richtig schmackhaft machen will wie eben
die hier auch die sehen ja alles so fein
püriert und richtig fein gemixt man
merkt keine fruchtstücke keine fasern
keine keine ingo stücke mit drin wenn
man das halt so machen möchte braucht
man halt wirklich so ein power blender
der das halt eben auch schach und
deswegen finde ich dir und sich so eine
anschaffung auf jeden fall jetzt möchte
ich euch noch zeigen wie man zum
beispiel etwas baby frei zubereiten kann
ich habe hier schon mal ein bisschen
haferflocken mit wasser aufgekocht das
gebe ich das unten
und da gebe ich jetzt ein bisschen obst
mit dazu ich nehme jetzt halten einen
frischen apfel mussten einmal entkernen
eigentlich noch ganz rein machen aber
also wenigstens musik macht können wir
den apfel komplett reinstecken
aber ich möchte jetzt dass der abt finde
ich ganz verkleinert wird es nirgends
kann ich trotzdem
und weil die kerne wird keinen frieden
aufs spiel setzt dann ganz klein war je
nachdem wie altes kindern ist müsst ihr
den drei ebenen kleiner machen oder eben
gröber lassen das ist so etwas kaum kam
und ich bin jetzt einfach ich habe auch
viel besser wenn ihr jetzt in uploader
das opfer mit rom mit rein gibt war dann
einfach die vitamine und nährstoffe noch
enthalten seien vor allem müsse es eben
schale benutzen denn da steckt ihr
steckt ja alles mit runter wenn ihr
eurem kind zum festlesen gibt die sind
ja meistens gebracht also dieses obst
und gemüse der dieses gemüse und die
welt kommen vitamine beispiel schon
verloren und startet heute nicht für
mein baby ist sondern richtig klein
vernaschen will möchte sie sind auch
nicht gleich total fein pürieren und
mixen und deswegen bin ich da jetzt die
punkte
die perfekte babybrei es geht es für
mich gleich noch etwas zimt mit reinem
geschmack aber wird jetzt auch so schon
richtig gut schmecken
ich werde in zukunft auch als in den
seebädern endlich da ist werde ich auch
meinen den preis selber machen und
meldete einfach die rezepte haben wollen
schreibt mir dann würde ich einfach alle
rezepte weg mache komplett als video
machen und euch das eben dann auch
zeigen
im prinzip habe ich jetzt alles rb die
leute einfach so ein paar rezept
beispiele gezeigt natürlich kann man
doch viel mehr noch machen also ich
könnte es ein pesto zeigen oder noch
ganz viele andere sachen budget
milchshake oder ein hostel es heute
passte genau rad oder einfach also da
gibt es auch ein kochbuch mit dazu das
ist so wie bei der kitchenaid ates an
dass man einfach so ein gutschein erhält
und den gutschein einschickt und daneben
ein kochbuch erhält zu meinem set gibt's
auf jeden fall immer mit dazu meine
kochschürze die wird vom design her ist
die fast ähnlich wie die jetzige
allerdings ein bisschen anders denn
diese hier habe ich ihr handgemacht und
hand bestickt und gedruckt und so kriegt
man es natürlich nicht hin in handarbeit
vor allem ich nicht und deswegen habe
ich mir ein schönes design einfangen
lassen
das gibt's zudem blender immer mit dazu
und es wird einfach noch was anderes mit
dazu gehen jetzt erst kurz nach zum
gewinnspiel
und zwar geht es um dieses philadelphia
gewinnspiel ich möchte mich bei euch
bedanken dass wir alle für mich
abgestimmt habt ich habe den contest
gewonnen also meine tochter hat den
contest gewonnen und ich habe jetzt
praktisch die produkte also diese preise
bekommen
das heißt die kitchenaid heavy duty den
kitchenette länder und das kochbuch und
in diesem video heute möchte ich gerne
die kitchenette heavy duty verlosen an
euch weil er ja mich unterstützt habt
und ihr könnt ihr jetzt dabei mitmachen
auch aus österreich genau ausschaut ist
er dieses gewinnspiel findet statt für
alle meine zuschauer aus österreich und
aus der schweiz
ihr dürfte zwar beim werden konnte es
nicht mit abstimmen wegen der
postleitzahl aber dürfte jetzt hier
mitmachen und zwar könnt ihr mir auf
facebook instagram oder youtube
kommentar hinterlassen
ihr könnt myvideo teilen müssten darauf
achten dass sie das öffentlich macht und
ich das praktisch
auch sehr geteilt hat und dann kommt ihr
alle praktisch per losverfahren in so
einen lostopf
und da gibt es online einfach so eine
seite wo ich dann praktisch per
zufallsprinzip gewinner ermitteln kann
ich bin zwar immer ziemlich blöd weil es
hat er nur einen gewinner gibt aber bei
dem gewinnspiel war sehr ich bin so das
man management dass jeder so ein viertel
des ipad gewinnen können und
philadelphia päckchen und ja da könnt
ihr jetzt mitmachen könnt fleißig
kommentieren bitte jeder nur einen
kommentar hinterlassen
die doppelten kommentare werde ich am
löschen und ich denke an sonst nicht
alles gesagt ich schreibe alles noch
eine infobox rein und verkündet an
demnächst den gewinner
ich lasse es gewinnspiel eine woche lang
laufen also genau sieben tage in einer
woche endet es dann und dann gibt es
praktisch einen oder eine glückliche
gewinnerin
ich freue mich aufs nächste mal so und
jetzt noch ein schlusswort nach dem
schlusswort ich wollte jetzt auch noch
mal betonen wie schon am anfang
gesund den euro zutaten gesund könnt ihr
kochen aber niemals eure küchenmaschine
die kann euch nur dabei unterstützen
eben bei der zubereitung und vor allem
finde ich noch ganz wichtig nehmt
einfach ganz normale zutaten die wir
hier vor ort haben unterstützt eure
regionen schaut nach saisonalen
produkten
ihr braucht keine wunder heilmittel wie
gucci bären oder irgendwelche cia samen
sondern ihr braucht einfach nur das was
vor ort wächst und was eben gerade jetzt
zur jahreszeit wächst und dann seid ihr
einfach bestens aufgehoben
nochmal ich es jetzt noch mal den preis
ja auch zu kauen kauf hätte ich jetzt
verschluckt